das liegt daran dass es daran liegt also
mein name ist herzlich willkommen in
deutschland hat heute das ziel von bio
das was max und ich habe uns hier
versammelt meine damen und herren zu
einer tür ein paar sekunden später so ja
ich finde sieger wir haben uns für diese
nicht lassen challenge einen kanal
rausgesucht meine damen und herren ich
will nicht sagen dass er ein kanal ist
aber eher heißt galilei was grüße gehen
raus grüße gehen raus
wir schauen uns hier verschiedene videos
vor dem anderen gerade geklingelt nicht
dass jetzt allerdings gab interferenz
halt dein maul ist ein ernst euro hoch
naja wir fangen locker anfang locker ein
solcher erfolg bei der jobsuche muss
natürlich gebührend gefeiert werden bei
einem xxl xxxl welcher wilder mitglied
ihrer tante marianne von der neuigkeit
berichten
das ist das wirklich seiner ganzen
geschichte war das bei xxxl besser wenn
ich meine leistung bei einem becher
bekommt einmal den größten haben mit
anlagen und ganz gewiss nicht aber
wirklich mithalten
ging doch weil ich glaube diese
max ich lache jetzt kein mal wieder mehr
ich auch das jedoch mit mit einer
schlimmen erreichte man ja nie das
kapital erhalten
mehr wehren kann ich mich da
normalerweise eher weniger
tja nicht lachen heißt riskieren okay
das will dass wir die last für die
lachen
er macht einfach irgendwas dann macht er
noch mal irgendwas und dann ist pause
in der tat dass jetzt jeder selbst mit
sonst nicht schere gebe
was ist da muss klar kommen auf mein
leben
danke die übertrieben einfach komplett
übertrieben
also reicht ich bin dass ralf dir ja ich
bin mal sehen ja deswegen hab ich kein
bart kann es ja noch meinen abgeben ja
alles zu spät
jetzt passen ja schon abgeben kann
von markus wagner bauen mit allahu
akhbar was du nicht sagst das ok boss
gefragt was hat er ausgesorgt gesagt sie
war krass freunde da gucken wir lieber
eine überlegte das gucken wir lieber
einen film über leere tische
obwohl anja danach aussieht befinden wir
uns nicht mitten in einer schlacht er
greift eine handvoll scheitert und
drückte ihn fressen gefakte war alles
klar ist aber nicht weltmeister sondern
das bedeutet gebaut häuser und vieles
mehr ausliegen
das ist die scheiße hier in der großen
zu großen wanne sie besteht aus
du hörst du ja okay für mich menschlich
sind ziemlich abstoßend
nein sagt und tut das tut es dabei der
claus kleber der aller zusammenhalt ich
mit leo wurde schon vor zehn jahren
gebaut
das liegt daran dass ist daran schon
wieder da wenn man zu zweit macht das
ausmaß reaktion du hast hier november
und da hast du verre konsolidiert
seitdem 2000 jahre später so weiter das
liegt daran dass es daran liegt man
findet ihr zum beispiel dort wo noch
einen kräftigen fig große pfützen
stehenbleiben sollte willkommen auf
lukas kanal übertrieben aber kraftlos
als fett oder man aber zeichnet vettel
enthält viel platz benötigt man um
stabile beine herzustellen
stabile schweizer erwischte hin
ich dachte man nutzen um auf eine wand
zu können wo leute reingelegt worden
ich lebe gerne ist aber auch für stabile
spannung ja kann man für viele sachen
verwenden
ich traurig sehr okay das werde ich klar
hatte man nämlich unter wasser kommt
direkt an die augen dann kommt das
wasser direkt an die augen als klar und
seit 16 jahren bin ich bei als den
einzelnen angeboten haben
telefon und internet 1&1 war hier
einfach die ganze werbung quasi für also
nur erfolgt ja einfach smart ist mit so
etwas anschaut mal da unten
das war es jetzt allerdings sie auch von
mir meine damen und herren max und ich
haben uns einige teile des
adventskalenders von galileo galilei wer
hat eigentlich galli galli lehm stimmt
oder haben wir heute gelernt checkt auf
jeden fall mal galileo auf youtube ab
max
ich bin eh nicht verlinkt der max ist
das leichter 25 3000 39 19
so fiel nach weniger des autos das was
ihr vom video das war es jetzt hier vom
video hier können jetzt jemanden kanal
abonnieren oder
meinen job ausschenken ihr findet ihr
zwei andere videos und wenn ihr sohn
abonnent sein können die auf die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen